this is one of the craziest people who
pulled off one of the biggest scams in
american history we are looking for
ericon for defrauding the u.s taxpayer
of more than 550 million dollars
[Music]
era khan was one of the biggest lawyers
here in appalachia the town loved him
and the people loved him he was a
phenomenon eric khan was mr social
security
[Music]
he was on the radio he was on television
this is an advertisement for eric c kahn
we laughed at him you know but everybody
wanted to meet him you couldn't miss him
especially when he went on the run
[Music]
the way he did it was incredible and
there was porn stars and voodoo dolls
and rolls royces and flashy suits and
brothels he opened a halloween themed
rock
nobody knows how many people he's been
married to everything about this guy is
too much to believe but it all happened
[Music]
at that time i thought he was helping me
i hit rock bottom lost everything i had
my clients are victims of his criminal
conduct this is one of the poorest parts
of the united states and he's getting
filthy rich off the whole thing hybala
in eastern kentucky
there was three investigations happening
at once bad judges bad lawyers bad
doctors my tires had been slashed with a
knife these were bad bad people i lived
in fear of going to work
the politics stink to high heaven only
playing government hates more than
rapists for a child molesters tax
evaders we're like freeze
we walked across the border with a dog
named curly through mexico into
guatemala we were that close now he's
gone eric was planning his biggest caper
yet
[Music]
you